my name is Etienne Donna and I work at
from research amoled architect and today
I'm going to talk about advanced use of
automatic machine learning functions so
these functions are automatic as a name
indicate but you can also customize them
a lot and that's what I'm going to talk
about today
everyone thank you for being here so I'm
going to talk today about some advanced
use of the automatic machine learning
functions so that may seem a little bit
contradictory because they're automatic
so what what what would you use them in
advanced way well it's because we try in
this function to have a bit the
possibility to use them as like full
automatic mode but also the possibility
to customize them a lot by changing and
a lot of pre-processing the method
wrapper parameters this sort of thing
that's one thing and also when you have
the model that has been trained to match
even if it's trained automatically you
can still do things these models such as
measure how good it is get information
about it or sometimes change the class
priors or the utility and this is
something that is not about automating
it's your own utility I mean I will talk
about that so that's the other thing
that I don't see done a lot in practice
and and that's why I'm giving this talk
to tell everyone like look there's all
this option there's all these
possibilities you can use them and and
and get you know the best out of of this
function ok so the automatic machine
learning functions I put here that
there's many I put here the main ones so
classify predicts this is like
supervised learning functions do
classification and regression learn
distribution this is a recent function
we added which is kind of the mania very
important function about unsupervised
learning it learns the distribution and
then with that you can do some
applications such as synthesizing the
missing values or finding the anomalies
okay find clusters to find rosters and n
dimensional addiction to kind of find
representation usually a numeric
representation that is small for each
example of data set so it's kind of
transforming a data set from something
big I mean if for example is big to
something where a choosing is awfully
small sort of compression but anyway
that's not going
so that's that's the main functions I'm
going to talk really about classified
today because that's the most used
function and actually what I will talk
most of it can apply to about everything
I mean especially predict land
distribution yeah fine cluster and
dimension prediction they use a
different automation we have to we have
to update them they still use a bunch of
heuristics
they're not super smart in the way they
are automated so some of the things
won't apply to this to some some will
but any case I think the richer function
is classified so ok so what is classify
and ok I could say what predict is as
well but it's be the same thing so
classify so ok automatic function to
learn a classifier so this is a simple
way to use it you just give it that a
set this means that when the input is 1
output it's a here when input is 2 the
output is a okay so it's four examples
in this data set and when you run it you
might have seen some anyway monitor
thing and then it returns a classifier
function and then you can use that on
new data for example I can say okay what
is the the class for one point six and
say ok one point thing is probably a and
I can also ask how sure are you about
it's by asking the probabilities and it
will say okay these are toy examples we
didn't really make sense but you know
it's like pretty damn confident it's a I
guess if I if I put something like two
point I don't know five two point six is
gonna be a little bit less confident
that it's a then B okay predict well the
same way but this time is for a numeric
output so I can also you know do like on
the pretty top function after training
it's what is the value you predict for
the input one point six I can also say
what is distribution that you predict
what is distribution of the prediction
basically and that's it alright so now
let's train that on images and I'm going
to use this example to show all this
customization
that was talking about so this is a data
set with 20,000 images that have been
tagged according to their label so this
is the five four this is 8 right so it's
just to recognize and return digit are
unclassified and can explain with what's
going on as well here so basically it's
trying a bunch of experiments and I can
see these experiments if I okay
so for example it gave 200 data point
for the method Laurie's declaration with
this hyper parameters and it gives 200
data point to launch aggression with
other parameters and that's the result
so by doing this experiment it's try to
predict what is the best method and best
a parameters and so on for the full data
set so that's that's basically the
automation that is inside so you see
that for now only small experiment have
been done but some have probably been
ruled out so this one you know I don't
know which one which one it is it's
knife base ok naive Bayes apparently
performs very bad on this small data set
so it's not going to be tested on the
high data set so that's kind of the
essence of the of the automation so now
this kind of three contender and then
you'll see that one one or two is going
to be trying to fool that I said and the
advantage of this procedure is that you
can obtain learning curves so you see
the learning curves here it's what was
the performance of the best model when
it has been given this amount of data
and here so that was the most
performance then we give more data and
know the performance
sorry it's a dynamic that problems and
you can see of course the more data you
give the better model perform overall
and which is actually pretty nice this
learning curve because it can help you
answer the question should I try to give
more data or not and if you see like a
sort of plateau like maybe this is one I
mean we have to see the end of the
computation then you might think well I
mean you never know if more data
we'll help on that but but it's it's a
good hint to look at this learning curve
and so you have this for this is for the
loss function which is actually the
likelihood okay that's something I
should say as well
this is accuracy okay I'm surprised
normally it goes higher I think it mists
the best one let's see what you don't
rain yet no I did okay your neighbor is
the best I wonder why okay I'm gonna
explain that what's happening after okay
so this our our classifier and so the
methodology equation has been been
selected which is a little bit
surprising but but I will explain why
after and then you can use that on you
so let's get let's do a test set and so
this is test data you always test your
model on data that hasn't been used for
training let's do a random choice all
right so this one or one is is not fun
enough okay these two so hopefully it
says it's a - yep okay so to be working
and now I'm going to talk now it was a
bit slow I'm going to just use 10000
example from now on because I'm going to
do this computation many times alright
so that was probabilities all right so
first let's talk about the high level
specification we can do the first one I
think the most important one is a time
goal so you can specify oh actually I
want the training to just take 20
seconds okay and you can also by doing
you know control equal specify any
quantity put minutes days and you can
see here that n is going to go much
faster toward the and spend way less
time trying thousands of configuration
on the lower training set side actually
you go actually it's already over I mean
also add less the less data so it's bad
comparison but okay so very important
I think the most important option
actually performance goal so again most
ample options this can allow you to tell
the model what trade-off it should be
doing so if you put okay if you put
memory for example classify will try to
find a small model right if you put
speed for performance goals so let's
let's try some point two one okay so I
mean a could put time goal as well why
not
and and then I could put performance
goal goes to memory and here so this is
a loss function but that's actually not
what selected in the end in the end it's
something that is combination of the
loss at the speed of the model of the
memory of the model yeah basically and
and that's why before Laurie secretion
was selected because for some reason I
guess nearest neighbors were performing
very bad in terms of memory or speed but
you can change that so okay this one
whose memory but I could also do quality
and quality won't care about the memory
won't care about the speed okay very
little like it's true if you have
something that takes one terabyte of
memory it might you know penalize it but
to only go for the best best prediction
so it's changing the internal utility
function that is used to select the best
model alright so that's the second most
important option now let's go to the
more lower level option one is a method
option so you have a list of method you
can specify let's see they're listed
here decision tree Graham boosted
trailer integration and so on you can
you know click on any of them and they
have their own documentation page the
detailed their hyper parameter and I'm
going to talk about that right now
so okay that's how you specify just
generically use this method but this
over here so let's let's stop it over
here actually they find
okay usually declaration but use the
sort of sub option l2 regularization and
set it to one this is in machine
learning you call that hyper parameters
here it's basically a sub option okay
and if we go to the page of large
circulation we can see all the possible
sub options so l1 let me put bigger for
you
l1 regularization l2 regularization and
optimization method that's three
possible sub option and that you can
specify using this syntax okay at least
and then whatever you want option
pattern after so that would be okay so
that's one way to have a more low-level
use of classified
another one is a preprocessor so here
change examples here I'm going so I can
use the option feature extractor to
process the data so segmented words
means well first basically you know
extract the words from from from the
data that's what that what this means
and I can also put a pure function this
is just a pure function so this was a
named feature extractor that you can see
in the in the in documentation you have
a bunch of filters that are named okay
but you can also put any pure function
and you can combine them as well that's
something like a few people know you can
do a list and and kind of say first do
to uppercase then do remove the ethics
then use a segmented world feature
extractor okay another thing that you
can do is to do that in two steps first
you extract the features so let using
the feature extraction function so here
it is actually we could do the fuller we
could do the full pipeline alright
that's that's the feature extractor and
then I could extract the features train
the classifier
okay so you see here the input
type is nominal sequence now it's not
text anymore because it has been
extracted treat has been trained on this
data alright that's the feature
extracted remove the critiques and put
everything into uppercase
so you yeah upper case then remove the
critique then the word I extracted but
then what you can do is actually plug
the feature extractor into your
classifier by doing classify first
argument is a classifier and then you
put the feature extractor and you go now
we have something that works on text
again so if I do a c2 of you know the
card should say cat okay that's that
some useful useful things sometimes you
want to do feature often you want to do
feature extraction on the side then
shrine and then put everything back
together okay now let's see how you can
control almost everything they feel a
little bit of automation but almost
everything so for that you first have as
explained before to fully specify the
method option so in the documentation
you just put a value for each of the sub
option okay then the next thing you you
you have to do in order to a full
control of what's happening so this is
really when you want to I don't know do
research or or you don't trust the
automation and you don't want to do your
own business okay orders to understand
how how the how the model works that can
be useful to you know get rid of all the
Frankie behind the curtain happening
so one thing you have to do is set feet
ratio to mini-mall because as I was
saying before feature extractor is a
pre-processing so we will process the
data but it doesn't replace the internal
feature extractor so you do some feature
extraction but then internally there's
still the automation that says oh I see
an image I'm going to do this as it
takes I'm going to do that blah blah
blah blah so with this it's going to do
the minimum it it can for example if you
put an image and you say trained
allergic reversion feature extractor of
minimo it's still going to transform
image into a vector it has to all the
way it just doesn't work but it won't
use a neural network to do that it's
like the simplest possible
pre-processing
that it does so that's that's that's you
you could you could if for example for
some reason the default feature
extractor will take time on sometimes
you know that that you know no feature
extraction is needed yeah I mean my
standardized it automatically and you
know that you shouldn't standardize and
do nothing you know loose aggression on
these numbers will work very well it
happens so so you can do that and okay
so so the second thing is to put
performance called direct training this
because you so here it's still doing
actually even if I specify everything
but whatever actually in that case even
if I specify everything it's still going
to do a learning curve and this is
because it even though there's only one
you see there's only one experiment that
is done but it so we already know which
configuration we're going to try on a
full data set but having a learning
curve is also nice for as I was
explaining before to know if you know
you are improving or not so that's why
it does it by default but if one remove
the learning curve you do direct
training and here it just doesn't do any
learning curve it just trained on so in
that case you train with a random
configuration but if you specify it will
train configuration you want and so if
you put everything together then you
have full control here you're guaranteed
that you know there's nothing nothing no
pre-processing no we're processing no
automation no feature extraction exactly
and you go that can be used for
benchmarking for example if you want to
benchmark some time I receive an email
say all your lost aggression is slower
than you know something else
you know you cannot really compare when
it's doing a full learning curve but
when you're doing something like this
you can definitely compare you know
Apple to Apple with some other other
thing all right that's how to get full
control okay now this was B's
I mean it's basically what you need to
know for training that's all the tricks
there is for training now I'm going to
talk about more I mean tricks for
understanding what your model is so one
thing is to use information and that's
really okay I know I know okay that's
weird
now let us train this one I need to do
actually not this one it's going to be
less fun I'm gonna train one that has
okay I'm just gonna train one there's a
full automation it's going to be more
interesting fully it's faster now all
right five minutes so okay so
information is kind of a main function
to as name indicate obtain information
about the model so things like that's
accuracy with its uncertainty that's a
method there's a lot of information that
you have by just you know over in your
mouth the mouse a lot of twin-tip so for
example here you can see that its
neighbors number is 10 the description
boosting is 0.5 that's nearest method
it's can you can staff things about the
evaluation time on your computer okay
that's interesting this is computed when
you call information so you see it's 3.4
millisecond for example but if I do it
again it might be a little bit different
like 3.39 here so if you give this
classifier to I don't know a server
that's going to run it or whatever you
can it's kind of benchmarking its speed
you can obtain the speed between
information okay and some of the other
information you can see the learning
curve you can see all the experiments
you can okay that that's useful to
actually look at maybe you know like
this one this one is regression you
might say well you know me I think that
this one could have perform good so
let's grab this
I have a parameter and then you put that
as a method option into classify and you
can so it can it's an interaction
between you and the automation and you
that's why I like to be a bit
transparent about you know what what's
happening under the hood you can ask
things like control P with information
and actually that all the properties you
can ask at least for this model ii can
also ask in your nearest neighbors
numbers like some of the i parameters
and one useful thing is method option
because this is the method it's you know
the configuration that has been selected
by the automation so then if I let's say
I get more data right I train something
and now I have twice the amount of data
well it's likely that the best
configuration is going to be the same so
I would put my new my new data and just
use the same configuration that has been
found before and it's very much faster
actually if I if I retrain on that
actually so it's classified and if I put
direct training for example because now
let's say I don't care about the
learning curve performance training this
is going to be much faster so that
that's a good trick I think this is
super good trick ok ok still I don't
have much time but anyway this is an
internal information
let me see there's something more
important oh there was a lot of things I
wanted to talk about okay very quickly
if you that's a classifier if you look
at you know you cannot do first I'm a
classifier see what's inside this
completely non documented but you can
see everything that is inside so you
know the process sauce usually their
name you know it's self-explanatory like
come from image and you understand what
it is so this can be useful if you
understand what's under the hood you can
see you know all the configuration that
I've been tested can convince yourself
that this one is the best you know by
looking at ok with the training set of
15 that was the
curacy it was a mini-course entropy
blablabla with the size of 1500 this was
a result and anyway this is really if
you want to do advanced thing but you
can go in you know usually you can
understand what's going on understand
how the automation works and actually
this is not documented but if you want
you can use what we use internally to
process the data so basically the idea
is to first convert these to what we
call ml data set and then you can create
processes you know like standardized
anyway that's some interesting what's
going on
okay oh I put on the processor okay and
it gives a new processor and so you know
and the resulting data anyway it's kind
of you know internally documented so you
can look I know people use it they like
it hopefully we can make that top level
at some point so that's something okay
measurements okay very quickly we have
something called classifier measurement
right and I just want to tell the
properties so you give it the classifier
as the first argument and the test set
as a second argument and then you can
ask a bunch of properties such as
accuracy accuracy baseline I mean
there's a bunch of things here I want to
tell what I think are important so for
example we could have a report this
gives you a bit of a bunch of
information including the coefficient
matrix you can ask for the confusion
matrix as well and it comes all
restricted this is computer metric
restricted to these three things but
more interestingly this is a confident
matrix restricted to the class that has
a most confused
so apparently one and seven in this
model are the most confused class you
can also ask for top confusion so
typically for our computers nine to a
computer seven okay you can also have
the worst classified example that's an
example that are badly classified which
often help you clean your data set or
improve the model so anyway I think
that's important
and properties okay maybe we can wait
that the speaker arrives easy here
oh it's you cheetah all right let's
continue it only for three minutes we
can do a quick transition okay so class
prions okay this I want to say because
that's I think underused things it's
that every model is probabilistic they
don't just give a decision they give
probabilities and this is super useful
because you know you can of course know
is a decision you know if it's confident
decision or not and one thing you can do
is change the class priors after you
train so you can train on your data but
then you may say okay on your test data
I know that fifty percent of the time
it's a nine so I will change the class
prior like this okay and then it's going
to be better because it adds extra prior
information and here is how you would
obtain the class priors and you see that
now nine is zero point five another
thing is undetermined a threshold which
is basically if the probability doesn't
read this threshold say in determinate
so if we do something like this and you
know okay and test is zero probably it
will send a terminate because I put a
very high threshold actually now so
let's add C to janna terminate yep
it does it but with the training data
but if your test data is different to
your training data it cannot do it so if
you know in practice you run your model
on some data that have a different
distribution then you can do that all
right
utility function I'm gonna finish with
this it's basically a way to specify
actually I would prefer you to I really
don't want you to miss the classify of
four as a nine for example and you can
do that by changing the G function so
the best is to take the default utility
function which is this one and then you
can
oops sorry or am I then you can do
classify again and you put the
classifier and then you say utility
function and I'm going to change it and
you know for example okay I don't want a
zero to be classified as a seven so I'm
going to put minus 0.3 or minus 0.5 year
and I just changed the utility function
that's useful you know for example we
don't want I don't know
a mushroom to be classified you prefer a
mushroom to be wrongly classified as
poisonous than normally classified as
eatable that's a classic thing all right
and maybe a last thing is that if you
want to export import you can use a WM
LF format and you just use the export
import and that's it thanks
[Applause]